Modele programowania to fundamentalne specyfikacje, które definiują
jak oprogramowanie jest strukturyzowane
i wykonywane — dostarczają framework
dla deweloperów do wyrażania algorytmów
i organizowania kodu, często abstrakcyjnie ukrywając niskopoziomowe szczegóły
leżącego sprzętu lub środowiska wykonawczego
różne modele pasują do różnych typów problemów
i architektur sprzętowych, oferując
różne poziomy abstrakcji
i kontroli — w tym rozdziale
omówimy kwantowe i klasyczne modele programowania
i zobaczymy, jak możemy je łączyć, żeby tworzyć algorytmy
w hi
zaczniemy od modelu programowania
dla komputera kwantowego — jednym z fundamentalnych modeli programowania
który jest znany prawie wszystkim deweloperom kwantowym
jest quantum circuit — nie będziemy wchodzić
w szczegóły quantum circuits
tutaj, bo mamy już wiele świetnych zasobów
w tym wykład Joan Waters
wspomnimy tylko, że circuit jest zbudowany z
zestawu linii zwanych drutami, które reprezentują qubity
a także gates, które reprezentują operacje na stanach kwantowych
oraz zestawu pomiarów
innym ważnym konceptem modelu programowania
dla
te prymitywy reprezentują najpopularniejsze zadania
które użytkownicy starają się realizować z komputerem kwantowym
w tej chwili dostępne są dwa prymitywy
Sampler i Estimator — Sampler daje ci możliwość
próbkowania stanu przygotowanego przez quantum circuit
a Estimator pozwala ci szacować wartość oczekiwaną
obserwowalnej dla układu w stanie przygotowanym przez twój quantum
circuit — ostatnim konceptem
o którym będziemy mówić w tej sekcji
jest transpilacja — transpilacja
to proces przepisywania danego wejściowego circuit
aby dopasować topologię konkretnego urządzenia
kwantowego
do wykonania na zaszumionych komputerach kwantowych
podobnie do klasycznych kompilatorów
procedura transpilacji stopniowo zmienia
strukturę circuit przez stosowanie zestawu przebiegów
teraz porozmawiajmy o klasycznych modelach programowania
jest wiele modeli programowania
dla klasycznych komputerów
ale w tym rozdziale skupimy się na dwóch
najpopularniejszym — równoległym programowaniu
i task workflow — używając tych dwóch modeli
w kombinacji z kwantowymi modelami programowania
można wyrazić praktycznie każdy hybrydowy
kwantowo-klasyczny workflow o dowolnej złożoności
model równoległego programowania
dzieli program na podproblemy, które mogą być wykonywane
jednocześnie — istnieją dwa główne paradygmaty programowania równoległego
równoległość z pamięcią współdzieloną i z pamięcią rozproszoną
dla naszych celów skupmy się na modelu pamięci rozproszonej
model pamięci rozproszonej
używa niezależnych procesów na oddzielnych rdzeniach
lub węzłach, gdzie każdy proces ma swoją własną pamięć
a komunikacja odbywa się przez przesyłanie wiadomości — istnieje
kilka konceptów, które warto znać
pierwszym jest proces
który jest niezależną instancją programu
działającą na oddzielnym rdzeniu
a także rank, który jest unikalnym identyfikatorem procesu
a następnie jest single program
multiple data — model abstrakcji
który jest modelem abstrakcji
dla obliczeń, gdzie jedna instancja programu
jest dystrybuowana do wielu węzłów
więc kod źródłowy jest ten sam
ale dane na tych węzłach są różne
wykonanie w modelu programowania równoległego
przebiega w następujący sposób
jeden program jest dystrybuowany do wielu węzłów
i uruchamia wiele równoległych procesów
przepływ sterowania programu jest dyktowany przez rank
czyli identyfikator procesu
a komunikacja odbywa się
przez przesyłanie wiadomości
model programowania task workflow
abstrahuje obliczenia do grafu lub DAG-a
gdzie każdy węzeł grafu to konkretne zadanie
lub job, a krawędzie to zależności i dane
i kolejność — przykłady można znaleźć w naszej dokumentacji
bo w końcu sekwencja, o której zawsze mówimy w kwantowym
obliczaniu: mapowanie, optymalizacja
wykonanie i post-processing
to model programowania task workflow
gdzie wszystkie zadania są wykonywane jedno po
drugim w potoku
ale z task workflows
nie jesteśmy ograniczeni do sekwencyjnej kolejności wykonania
i możemy wykonywać zadania równolegle
każde zadanie lub workflow może być całym równoległym jobem
samo w sobie, więc możesz mieszać
i dopasowywać te modele, żeby opisać algorytmy
o dowolnej złożoności.
Spróbujmy zastosować niektóre z konceptów, których się nauczyliśmy
w kodzie — najpierw spróbujemy uruchomić proste hello world
używając paradygmatu programowania równoległego
będziemy używać Open MPI
który jest implementacją protokołu MPI
będącego standardem do przesyłania wiadomości
w programowaniu równoległym
najpierw musimy mieć gotowy nasz program
tutaj używamy mpi4py
czyli bindingów Pythona
dla MPI i jak widać używamy rank, żeby decydować
o przepływie sterowania programu
więc sprawdźmy nasz skrypt do przesyłania zadań.
Jak widać będziemy używać dwóch węzłów
jedno zadanie na węzeł na normalnej partycji
i uruchommy nasz program — poczekamy chwilę
i możemy sprawdzić wyniki naszego joba
jak widać mamy wyjścia logów naszego programu
tutaj używamy dwóch węzłów i dwóch procesów
które są identyfikowane przez rank
jak widać tutaj w wyjściu
rank zero i rank one, które służą do decydowania
o przepływie sterowania naszego programu
jak widać proces rank zero wysłał
jakiś payload do procesu rank one
a proces rank one przyjął
ten payload — porozmawiajmy też o task workflows
istnieją narzędzia zwane systemami
zarządzania workloadem — są specjalnie zaprojektowane
do uruchamiania złożonych workflows
ale żeby cię nie przeciążyć, będziemy używać wbudowanej
funkcji zależności w Slurm
żeby konstruować te grupy obliczeniowe
najpierw musimy mieć gotowe zadania naszego workflow
to jest ten sam kod
zaletą posiadania każdego z tych zadań
jak mapowanie, optymalizacja, wykonanie
i post-processing jako oddzielnych kroków
jest to, że możemy określić unikalne wymagania zasobów
dla każdego z zadań — na przykład mapowanie, optymalizacja
i post-processing nie potrzebują
dostępu do zasobów kwantowych
dlatego możemy uruchomić je na partycji klasycznej.
Ale zadanie wykonania będzie potrzebować
zasobów kwantowych, więc uruchomimy je na partycji
kwantowej.
Teraz użyjmy funkcji zależności, żeby połączyć zadania
w workflow.
Jak widać nadal uruchamiamy
nasze polecenie sbatch z flagą parsable
które zwróci ID joba
a następnie możemy przekazać to ID joba
jako zależność do innych zadań
dla jobów — jak widać uruchamiamy
joby w workflow z zależnością
gdy cały workflow jest gotowy, możemy sprawdzić wyniki.
I jak widać mamy z powrotem naszą wartość oczekiwaną.
I możemy też sprawdzić wszystkie
wyniki z każdego z kroków.
Które też tutaj są.
I to tyle w sekcji o modelach programowania
w następnym rozdziale będziemy rozmawiać o zaawansowanych
algorytmach